i just can't believe that it took me
this long to be like shave your head get
into this doja cat debuting a bold new
[Music]
did i look it
and explaining to her fans why she went
bold and bald
uh
um we have questions and doji cat
delivered some answers about her drastic
new do during an instagram live i feel
like i i was never supposed to have hair
anyway
i like don't like having hair
i never liked having hair
i cannot tell you one time
since the beginning of
my life that i've ever been like this is
cool
fair enough and we gotta say the buzz
cut works for the quirky emcee go to
town with it and she shave it all off
charlie brown with it still doges
makeover is receiving mixed reviews from
fans
some saying she stole millie bobby
brown's look as 11 on stranger things
is there a number we can call for your
parents where's your hair
others completely praising doja for
taking a risk and totally slaying the
hairstyle and then there are fans who
are just straight up concerned we all
know what people say about women getting
extreme haircuts
[Music]
but for doja it all comes down to
convenience especially when breaking a
sweat in the gym i'd be working out
but like i couldn't focus because i was
more
concerned with how i looked and how my
hair was
doing and like how to keep it
adhered to my to my scalp and then like
it would slide off and then i'd put on a
beanie it's just a nightmare dude
i'm over it i'm really liking this
it's what what is the use of having hair
if you're not gonna
wear it out doja is filling her due and
newfound freedom oh my god
i'm very excited i'm very very excited
still many are literally raising their
eyebrows after she took her shaved look
a step further doing this
[Music]
did i do it
yup that's dogecat pulling out her razor
to shave off her eyebrows next it's
crazy
while we didn't get an explanation for
why she buzzed her brows doja assures
fans on her live chat that she's okay
all the country girls in my in my chat
are
are you okay seth
i'm fine terry jo
i'm just fine
i'm doing dandy
[Music]
you